[Music]
i am pulsing boot
holy freak
hey giant
you want to see something cool
[Music]
and how many times have you died already
uh
no poison but doesn't need a spotter
watch
watch
a cat always lands on his feet watch
you are down to your last life mama
lunas always on the lookout for a new
lap cat i have no lap cat i am [ __ ]
boots not anymore
[Music]
this is a person potty pickle that's
your party so this is where dignity goes
to die liver
don't look like the pickles well
you don't look like a cat
full disclosure i'm a therapy dog why
were my belly
hard buzz
they found me
goldilocks and the three bears crying
make her talk
excuse me my darling we're looking for
the legendary [ __ ] boots have you
perhaps
seen him
what a puss in boots he
is me
oh
[Applause]
normally i have a sword he's like a
whole thing okay
get that cat dead or alive will be just
right bounty hunters kitties
i need your help whenever i team up with
you things go wrong cool another member
of the team i'm pussy's therapy dog
definitely not finally you need therapy
oh i have got to learn how to do that
lives flashing before your eyes pray for
mercy from persian birds
[Music]
espresso
[Music]
i don't trust you trust me
you gotta trust him look at those eyes
you killed that cute no
and with the paws am i doing it stop
you're gonna give yourself a hard
[Music]
bye